Grace and peace to you this morning.
Church, it's great to see you.
If you're new with us, we're so glad that you're here.
Uh, we know it's a big deal to take that step
and so we'd love to get to meet you
and get to know you if we can.
So, um, there's a QR code in front of you if you can do
that, or there's a new area out there.
We'd love to just to, to bless you as you've blessed us
with your presence here today.
Uh, by the way, there, there's been a lot of new people
around here these last couple weeks and,
and so if this is your home already,
if you're consider yourself a Henderson Hills person,
make it your mission to welcome everyone every week.
Like that could be your job.
Uh, my job, every one of us as best we can.
Uh, but also if you could make it a point,
I know nobody loves sitting on the front row except
for a few of you, but if you could sit forward
and inward, uh, our new friends often like, look for seats,
kind of easy to find.
And those are the edges and the backs.
And so just make it a, a thought process as you come in.
Say, may I sit a little forward and in
and let those seats be found easier for people
who might be coming in a little bit later.
Let's not make it harder for people
to feel like this is home, uh, like this is family.
So let's make it our priority for that.
So we're currently walking through this first things first
series where we're studying the most important doctrines
of our faith first.
Uh, later we'll shift to the less important doctrines, kind
of show how that fits in around the big rocks.
But, but we're just gonna review regularly
just so we get them in our heads.
What are the things not, again, it's not exhaustive,
but these are seven that we're saying are the big rocks.
And so the first one, a few weeks ago now,
what was the first one that we looked at?
Revelation. Revelation. Okay, we're catching on.
We're picking up. All right. Revelation is
that God has told us about himself.
Otherwise we wouldn't know very much about God.
This is the first one God told us about himself.
Second was what he told us about himself. What was that?
God's attributes. What God is, who God is.
We wanted to make sure we understood that as we go.
Now the third rock, which I probably should have done,
the biggest rock for this one,
but uh, the third one was,
what did God tell us about himself, specifically Trinity,
that God is three persons, one God, same divine essence.
That is one of the most distinguishing
marks of Christianity.
Well then we added a fourth one last week
and it was what God, the Son, the incarnation that
God has added on a human nature to save us,
to become like us so we could be like him.
Now, so far all of our big rocks have focused on God.
They've been directed vertically.
And today we're gonna shift our eyes a little bit to try
to answer some of the most foundational questions
that people have about life, about life in general.
See, probably more than any time in history,
people are asking questions about identity,
about trying to figure out who they are, why they exist.
It's rampant.
And students, you're pressed up against this every single
day as influencers
and even friends select
and modify their identity, who they claim to be.
But in reality, it's every single one
of us is facing this every day.
Just think about how people cultivate their
image on social media.
Only putting forward the best parts of who I am.
And, and this is what I want you to know about me,
but I don't want you to know really who I am.
And then you add to that,
this constant pull toward finding our identity in a
political outcome
or a sports team or a job
or a financial status that we have versus other.
That's we are all tempted to find identity
in those things and many more.
That's why our big rock today will examine
what God's word says about humanity,
about mankind, humans,
this is essential.
Now the question you might ask like
why is that a foundational rock?
It's not about God. Well, it's about us.
Yes, because if we don't get this right,
we won't understand our relationship with God.
First. We won't understand salvation.
In essence, we'll start looking
for identity in all these wrong places
and we'll treat each other very wrongly.
That's why this is foundational.
So it's gonna be a bit of a roundabout journey,
but we're gonna start in James chapter three
to get us down the road
to understanding humanity a little bit better.
And so turn to James three with me in God's Word
all the way in the New Testament.
Later in there New Testament John, uh, sorry,
James chapter three.
And we're gonna look at James three, one through 12
and we're gonna see what the Holy Spirit inspired James
to write about our words.
See how this gets us down the road with humanity as we go.
James three, one through 12.
Not many of you should become teachers, my brothers,
for you know that we who teach will be judged
with greater strictness for we all stumble in many ways.
And if anyone does not stumble in what he says,
he's a perfect man able to also bridle his whole body.
If we put bits in the mouse of horses.
So they obey us, we guide their whole bodies as well.
Look at the ships also though they're so large driven
by strong winds, they're guided by a very small rudder
wherever the will the pilot directs.
So also the tongue is a small member, yet it boasts
of great things, how great a forest is set a blaze
by such a small fire.
And the tongue is a fire, a world of unrighteousness.
The tongue is set among our members,
staining the whole body, setting on fire.
The entire course of life set on fire by hell for every kind
of beast and bird of reptile
and sea creature can be tamed, has been tamed by mankind,
but no human being can tame the tongue.
It's a restless evil, full of deadly poison.
With it, we bless our Lord and Father
and with it we curse people who are made in the likeness
of God from the same mouth come blessing
and cursing my brothers.
These things ought not to be.
So does a spring pour forth from the same opening both
fresh and salt water?
Can a fig tree my brothers bear olives
or a grapevine produce figs?
Neither can a salt pond yield fresh water.
God, this is your word.
We pray that you would show us what you want us
to see here very clearly that this would not be something
that we, as James says earlier, merely hear.
But we actually do not just be here is
the word but doers of the word.
And we know we can't do that as we just saw.
We can't tame our tongues. We can't do this ourselves.
God, we need your work, your change in us. So start with me.
Start with us that we would walk towards you in holiness,
in your power for your glory, for others good
in Jesus' name, help us.
Amen. So I wanna walk briefly through this passage
to show first how James teaches
what he's talking about here,
but then also what it'll springboard us into a discussion on
humanity and all the things we talked about here.
And so he started notice with a, a passage on
teachers in which he includes himself.
He says, we who teach will be judged
with greater strictness.
Now why is it true that teachers are
judged with greater strictness?
'cause we who teach are instructing others.
He's talking not just teachers in general in the faith,
teachers of the faith, people who are teaching about
who God is, who're leading through our teaching,
whoever's teaching, helping direct lives,
answering questions and so on.
That's why this is such a big deal.
And so James' point saying, you better be careful with
what you say as a teacher.
And he says, why? Because verse two says,
we all stumble in many ways with even our words.
We all get off track even as teachers,
we can lead people astray by us getting astray.
And he gives us a couple of great illustrations
to prove his point about this idea of the tongue.
First he uses this idea of a bit in the mouth of a horse.
Now a bit is a small piece of metal you put in their mouth
and it's got a ring on each end of it.
And it connects to the straps that the rider holds in order
to control the direction the horse should go.
And it's tiny though.
It's so small, it's how the rider controls the horse, right?
Similar for our words for us.
As the tongue goes, the body will follow.
He also uses second this picture of a ship with a rudder.
That rudder is the small part on the back of the ship
that's tiny relative to the size of the rest of the ship.
But it is powerful
because that's how the pilot steers the ship.
James says that similar to the tongue, that it is so small
but it has an outsized influence on the rest of the body
and how true that is, right?
I mean, just think about the old saying that we teach kids.
I think you shall note, as soon as I start saying it, sticks
and stones let's go, can break my bones,
but words can never hurt me.
False. Now I get
the sentiment, I get the point, right?
You can kind of choose to listen
or not listen, I get that point.
But our words do so much damage, right?
Whether it's lies
or gossip, slander, harsh words,
simply talking someone down.
That's why Jesus said in Matthew 1236,
a fearsome verse, he said, on the day of judgment,
people will give account for every careless word they speak,
every flippant comment, every
harsh word just tossed on that.
He says they're all being recorded.
And that's not only to teachers.
He's talking about that to all of us.
And why does he say that?
He says that because our words can hurt people.
That's the rest you saw of James three five.
He says, how great a forest is set ablaze
by such a small fire.
Like it doesn't take more than a spark to set acres
of land ablaze.
In high school, my my friend
and I were foolishly setting off fireworks in a wheat field
that had just been plowed after harvest.
And so I happened to have one of those strobe lights
that just flashes really bright.
And I started it and tossed it out in the field
and it starts to flash
and all of a sudden we start to see some flames.
And all of a sudden we saw it starts
to spread pretty quickly and it's two of us.
And this thing is starting to go quick.
And so we moved as fast as ever moved in my life
to go kick dirt and dirt and dirt.
And then you're kicking more stubble on top.
It's starting to flame up. Praise the Lord.
We're able to stop it.
But um, it's a picture of
what happens when we toss one little flame.
The whole thing starts place.
That's Why we have to be so careful with our words.
'cause verse six, he says, the tongue is a fire.
It's a world of unrighteousness.
Like even more than that song, that baby, it's a firework.
Like this is what we're talking about.
Our words can start forest fires.
It reminds me, you remember the old Smokey the bear
campaign, US Forest Service, right?
Remember the picture? What's this slogan?
Only you can prevent forest fires.
Is that not true for us today in life?
It's up to each one of us
to keep from scattering sparks on the dry ground
of people's lives all around us.
'cause that's the reality, right?
Every one of us is struggling.
Every one of us has this, this stubble,
this dry ground in our lives.
And if we start scattering sparks all over everybody,
it's gonna be blazes.
Let's be careful with our words, careful
with our Facebook comments.
Be careful with our Snapchat posts. How they disappear.
No, let's be careful
with our text threads about someone else.
Let's be careful with our emails
because look again at verses nine
through 12 here in James three,
this is James continuing his argument.
He's still talking about the same thing.
But notice he says it here referring to brothers
when he says brothers,
he's meaning the church fellow Christians.
He's talking to believers.
So look at what he says, nine through 12 with it,
with our tongues, we bless our Lord and Father.
And with it we curse people who are made in the likeness
of God from the same mouth come blessing
and cursing my brothers.
These things ought not to be so.
Meaning the church is participating in this,
does a spring pour forth water from the same opening both
fresh and salt water?
Can a fig tree bear olives or a grapevine? Produce figs? No.
Neither can a salt pond yield freshwater.
Like so. You see what he says here to the church?
He says, somehow we have justified in our minds
that we can praise God in here
and sing these great songs and then walk out there
and gossip and slander and cut down brothers
and sisters cursing them.
How does that work? I mean, James is
as confused as anyone.
He's saying, how can from the same mouth come blessing
and cursing?
He says, these things ought not to be.
So it's wrong and it's not the way it should be.
What he's saying here basically is that a Christian,
a the words a Christian uses should be very different
than the words that everyone else uses.
'cause think about the last illustrations.
He, he James is great at illustrations.
So look at the last couple illustrations he gives.
What what he means by these is that if,
if someone's been made a new creation by the Lord, then
what they say should reflect
that they are a new creation.
So he, he gives the illustration of a spring of water.
Is it possible for that spout
to put out both fresh and salt water at the same time?
No. The source
is only one of those two.
It's either salt water or it's fresh water.
If there's any mixture, it's salt water
or, or think of a fig tree, which by the way,
I was growing up in a time when,
when fig newtons were kind of popular.
I, I, I knew they existed
and all I knew is they were terrible cookies.
But it wasn't, listen, it wasn't
until like a couple years ago that I finally put it together
that those are made with fix.
Like legitimately, I was clueless.
Just thought that was the name figs and oh wow, okay,
but when you get a fig tree,
will you get olives off of a fig tree?
No. It's logic.
We understand this similarly, like you have a grapevine
and you're walking down the, the vineyard rows
and you're, you're picking figs off the
grapevine and snacking, right?
No, you get grapes off a grapevine just like you see it back
in Genesis five all the way from the beginning.
It talks about when we bear children as humans, we
reproduce according to our likeness, According to
who we are, our nature.
You cannot bring forth something
that is not corresponding to your nature.
Fig tree, figs, olive tree, olives, that's the point here.
A truly transformed heart will produce the things
that God wants to produce
rather than producing the things set on fire By hell.
James says, the ways of the world around us.
Now, we're not gonna do that perfectly yet.
We understand that that's still coming.
On the day that Jesus returns Philippians one, six,
he'll complete the work that he began in you.
That's still one day for us
to perfectly produce the things God wants.
But our goal now should be
to tame our tongues just talking about this one thing,
tame our tongues more
and more in the power of the Spirit of God
so that our lives reflect that image
of God more like Ephesians four says, we should
therefore having put away falsehood, let each one
of you speak the truth with his neighbor.
For we are members one of another.
Let no corrupting talk come out of your mouths,
but only such as is good for building up
as fits the occasion
that it may give grace to those who hear.
Do not grieve the Holy Spirit of God
by whom you were sealed for the day of redemption.
He's saying, our words can grieve the spirit of God.
Let all bitterness and wrath and anger and clamor
and slander be put away from you along with all malice.
Be kind to one another, tenderhearted, forgiving one another
as God in Christ forgave you.
That's the image of God
reflected in our words.
But why is this such a big deal?
Why does James like, why does he make such a big deal?
Why should we be so concerned about this?
James three, nine, look at it again.
This is really his whole reason for writing this.
James says, he wants our words to match our theology,
to match what we believe.
Look again, verse nine,
with our tongues, we bless our Lord and Father.
And with it we curse people
who are made in the likeness of God.
See, this is where we're gonna jump onto this big rock
of humanity because his reason
for not speaking the way that we often speak is
because people are made in the image of God.
And so the fundamental question we need to start with here
as we talk about humanity is this question, who are we?
It's the question everybody's asking, who am I?
Well, thankfully God's word gives us that answer.
And verse nine gave us a clue
that we are made in the likeness or the image of God.
And that idea comes all the way from the beginning,
from the first page of your Bible.
Genesis one, where God created everything.
Genesis 1 26 and 27 says this.
Then God said, let us make man or mankind
or humanity in our image after our likeness.
Let them have dominion over the fish of the sea, the birds
of the heavens, the livestock over all the earth,
over every creeping thing that creeps on the earth.
So God created man in his own image, in the image
of God in created him, male and female, he created them.
But what does it mean to be created in the image of God?
Because that, that thread runs through the whole scriptures.
It starts in Genesis one. It goes all throughout.
You can find it here and here and here
and here even into James three, even beyond James three.
What does it mean? The image of God?
Well, okay, just let's think about
when you look in a mirror.
Some of you didn't this morning,
but I'm not gonna say like, okay,
When you look in the image, you look in the mirror.
What do you see? You see the reflection of your image.
That's a similar idea.
It's not exact to this, but in a similar way.
To be in the image of God is we are to reflect God
as he made us like him in many ways.
His character, his personality, his nature, his heart,
his actions like who he is,
which means you can learn a little bit about
God by looking at humans.
Not everything but a little bit.
If we're made in his image,
a further step is that Colossians one 15 says,
Jesus is the image of the invisible God.
And he's perfectly the image of the invisible God.
Meaning when you looked into the face of Jesus,
you saw God, right?
Saw that last week. He is God.
And so he's the image, the visible representation to us,
the way we know him to a lesser extent.
That's how God designed humans to be as well.
Because in the story of creation, no other creation piece
was created in the image of God.
Only humans. Just,
just stop for a second with that.
Think of the value of humanity
Then Everyone,
because there's not a person who's ever lived
that was not made in the image
of God valuable.
Every one of us. That's why
our church's value of compelling love says
that we demonstrate the love of Jesus
by respecting the dignity of every person,
sacrificing for our neighbors, cultivating unity
with our faith family again.
Why? Because every person's made in the image
of God just like I am.
So there's dignity, there's value that I need to show
and love them like that.
Each man walking around on the face
of the earth is an independ,
independently valuable creation.
Each woman walking
around on this earth is an independently valuable creation.
And listen, I I'm gonna add a caveat to that one,
because it's not just
because she's with a man that she's valuable.
In fact, it's often in spite of the man she's with,
She's That she's valuable.
Need to be reminded of that.
Sometimes I think independently valuable
creations, every single person who's walking around the face
of the earth, who ever has every will,
independently valuable creations
because of the image of God.
That means when we start treating people like they are
property or like they are transactions
or like they are animals or like they are not even people.
We deny God's image in that person.
But the follow up to who we are is the question then
why are we first?
Who are we? But then why are, why do we exist?
Why are we even here? Well,
you go back to Genesis one.
God gave our first parents, Adam
and Eve, he gave them a task.
He said, be fruitful and multiply.
Have dominion over the earth. Fill it, subdue it.
That's still one of our tasks today.
In the image of God, in our parents' task, along
with relating to God, relating to others is kind
of threefold, relate to nature,
relate to God, relate to others.
But here's how God says it. Isaiah 43 7.
He says, everyone who's called by my name, whom I created
for my glory, Whom I formed and made.
See that's the way believers have said
it for thousands of years.
Why we are here is to glorify God.
That's why first and foremost, that's it.
We were created for his glory, not for our own glory.
Not to make ourselves famous or even comfortable.
Our job, our first task, what we are created to do is
to lift high the name of the Lord
and to make much of him with our lives.
Every one of us. That's also why
Second Corinthians five calls us as believers,
his ambassadors.
'cause think about what an ambassador does.
They are official representatives of one nation to
a foreign nation.
They are to uphold the values
and beliefs of their home nation, representing it even
as they work to engage the foreign nation
that is home for them.
Same for us today.
Christian, listen, this means
this world is not our home.
This is not all there is. God is building our eternal home.
And that's an eternal home with him face to face.
So let's, let's be careful
that we are not acting as if this is all there is
and living in light of nothing to come.
That we better maintain this as the highest good.
No, there's there's better coming.
That's true home as well.
But here's the beauty of this doctrine of humanity.
It teaches us that this world actually does matter.
That our bodies actually matter.
'cause God didn't create us as ghosts
or as some kind of being that's just sort of floating.
He created us with bodies.
Yes, they're temporary, but they're not throwaway.
This world is temporary, but it's not throwaway.
We are to treat it and to treat our bodies
and to treat others with the dignity of the image
of God in them, just like in us.
But here's where the problem comes.
We look around in this world
and we see broken relationships.
Instead of the perfect one that Adam and Eve had
before the fall of sin.
We see broken knees.
We see cancer, we see death.
And so we think, all right, this is why we're here.
This is who we are. What went wrong then?
'cause this is a mess. We need to call it out.
This is a mess. What went wrong?
Why are things not perfect the way they once were?
Well, we're gonna hit this a lot more next week when we talk
about salvation as one of our big rocks.
But the problem comes just three chapters into the Bible.
When sin entered the world, We want to answer
to why everything is a mess.
Because of chapter three of Genesis.
When Adam and Eve chose to disobey God,
they chose to eat the fruit.
Everything fractured at that moment.
The openness and honesty they once had
with God was now hiding from God and blaming other people.
The freedom that they once had together
with each other was now filled with shame and covering.
It's what we refer to as the fall of humanity, the fall
of mankind where every one of us who has the seed
of Adam is now counted guilty as well
because of what he did.
It's Not fair. It's just part of the way it is
because he's our head in that way.
We also have a head in Christ.
We'll get to that in a second. That counts for us.
So we better believe that he can count for us,
but we are affected in our bodies.
We get sick, we get injured, we die the world.
It's hard because of
that, we're affected in our bodies.
We're also affected in our souls
where we have a sinful disposition from conception.
Just look at these kids running around, right?
They're not little perfect angels.
You have to teach 'em how to sin.
It's because of this. We're totally depraved.
We're unable to do good before God.
And that poisoned salt pond that's in there
is why we spew venom on each other.
It's all because of the fall of humanity.
Because sin, it makes us guilty by our sin as well.
But it's because sin broke everything.
Okay, so what's the solution then?
What's the solution?
It's that we need a heart transplant it.
We need new hearts. We need new spirits.
We need to be made new creations.
That's the answer to this problem.
It says, God says it in Ezekiel 36.
Listen To how he says this.
I will give you, this is him predicting what's
coming a couple hundred years later.
He says, I'll give you a new heart,
a new spirit I will put within you.
I'll remove the heart of stone from your flesh,
give you a heart of flesh.
I'll put my spirit within you
and cause you to walk in my statutes
and be careful to obey my rules.
See the only answer, the solution to our problem.
Specifically, let's talk today about our words.
The only solution is not trying harder.
It's not putting a quarter in the jar every time you curse.
It's not building up accountability around you.
The true solution is that we need new hearts.
We need the springs of our hearts
to be producing fresh water, not salt water anymore.
We need the trees of our hearts to be producing good fruit,
not the wrong kind of fruit.
Listen, if if our tongue, James said it,
if our tongues are set on fire by hell,
then we need the living water of the gospel to come
and quench that fire, don't we?
To put that fire out the the living water of Jesus
to spring up from within us
and quench the fire
that is just present within us from birth.
That's What we need. And that starts
by confessing your sin.
You confess your problem with words to the Lord, asking
for his forgiveness, giving your life to him
because of his great love
and grace for you in spite of yourself
that then second Corinthians five 17,
if anyone is in Christ, if's a new creation.
When you confess and repent and believe He receive
and receive his forgiveness, he makes you this new creation.
Then though, here's the trouble.
Once that is true of us,
then we must soak in his living water to quench any fire
that still remains in us.
We've gotta abide in Jesus, in His word, in His spirit,
gotta fill that sponge of our hearts with,
with his living water, not with the water
of the world or the flesh.
Because if we don't soak in him, abide in him.
If we allow our sinful flesh to dominate,
Galatians five says, the things we get are strife, jealousy,
fits of anger division.
But if we instead allow the spirit of God to dominate,
it says we get things like love, joy,
peace, patience, kindness, goodness, faithfulness,
gentleness, self-control.
And if that is the new heart, God's building in you,
that comes out of our words first
and foremost, remember, out of the heart, the mouth speaks.